er hat sich ja schon tausendmal gehört
der amerikanische dollar ist die
reservewährung der welt
die leitwährung unseres planeten und wir
alle kennen den ein oder anderen
klugscheißer freund da denkt er wisse
alles über geopolitik und behauptet dass
es sich bei dieser vorherrschaft des
dollars um den eckpfeiler der
sogenannten neuen weltordnung handelt
den illuminaten bilderbergern und george
soros sei alles zuzutrauen
diese vorherrschaft zu zementieren
[Musik]
ok wie wäre es wenn wir diesen
selbsternannten experten mal auf den
zahn fühlen und ihnen nur eine kleine
frage stellen was bedeutet es wirklich
dass der dollar die leitwährung nummer
eins ist
ich meine inwieweit profitieren die
vereinigten staaten selbst von einer
währung die den internationalen handel
dominiert ist es wirklich so wichtig und
vor allem könnte er durch andere
währungen wie den euro
chinesischen yuan ersetzt werden heute
werden wir euch all diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir dies tun
lasst uns mal wieder einen blick in die
geschichte werfen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
falls er visuell politik schon seit
längerem verfolgt wisst ihr bereits dass
sich argentinien in einer notlage
befindet und bei internationalen
investoren um kredite betteln muss in so
einem fall gibt das land normalerweise
so genannte staatsanleihen aus dies ist
ein stück papier in dem der staat
verspricht wenn du mir einen geldbetrag
ist werde ich dir diesen sagen wir in
zehn jahren zuzüglich zinsen
zurückzahlen
[Musik]
so weit so gut aber stell dir nun
folgende situation vor
nehmen wir an du läufst der
argentinischen regierung 3000
argentinische pesos zum zeitpunkt als
dieses video gedreht wurde im sommer
2008 zehn entsprachen diese drei tausend
pesos in etwa 100 amerikanischen dollars
aber wie steht der kurs im jahr 2028
also in zehn jahren wir wissen es nicht
wahrscheinlich wird es diese schon oft
zu einer weiteren abwertung der
argentinischen währung kommen und dann
wirst du dir für diese drei tausend
pesos nicht mal eine tüte doritos kaufen
können
aus diesem grund sagen internationale
investoren so schauen sie nun mal sind
wenn argentinien zu ihnen kommt und geld
will haye warten alter okay ich leide
das geld aber mach dir keine sorgen
deine schuld wird in dollar angegeben
amerikanischen dollars auf diese weise
gebe ich dir 300 dollar und ist mit 300
dollar plus zinsen zurück gab es ja
meine lieben zuschauer so schützt sich
ein anleger vor möglichen abwertungen
aber womit wir reden hier doch nicht nur
über argentinien in der tat wählen die
meisten länder der welt den greenback
als eine währung in der sie ihre
schuldscheine ausstellen und deshalb
können sie schlagzeilen wie die folgende
in jeder finanzzeitung lesen die
mexikanischen regierung wird auf dollar
lautende schuldverschreibungen begeben
die in zehn jahren fällig sind
wer euch vorstellen können sprechen wir
ja nicht nur von regierungen
immer wenn zum beispiel aramco die
staatliche ölgesellschaft schaudig saudi
arabiens ihren bio saft beispielsweise
an indien verkaufen will sagt sie hey
alter was sind das für krasse
münzenrieder andrehen willst ich weiß
noch nicht mal wie viel die wert sind
nicht mehr als du zahlst schön in
dollars amerikanischen dollars denn der
währung traurig dies erklärt warum 60%
devisenreserven den zentralbanken in
dollar lauten
[Musik]
weltweit sind mehr als 1,65 millionen
dollar im umlauf und mehr als die hälfte
von ihnen befinden sich außerhalb der
usa es gibt kein internationales gesetz
das besagt dass der dollar die globale
referenzwährung ist ein muss aber die
meisten menschen vertrauen dieser
währung wenn sie international handel
treiben
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt die eigentliche frage
ich meine wie profitiert amerika davon
dass seine währung überall zirkuliert
kommt darauf an den meisten unternehmen
und otto normalverbraucher kann dies
völlig schnuppe sein wie er würden sogar
so weit gehen zu behaupten dass diese
dadurch zu einige nachteile haben aber
für die amerikanische regierung
cubadebate normalen leitwährung zu sein
ist wie ein geschenk des himmels
wieso weshalb warum wir erklären es euch
klipp und klar
[Musik]
für eine handvoll dollar wir haben es
hier bei visual politik tausend mal
gesagt das schlimmste was einem land
passieren kann ist hyperinflation
dies bedeutet dass die preise plötzlich
explodieren
aber wie entsteht hyperinflation ihr
wisst die antwort bereits in den meisten
fällen ist dies zu hundert prozent ein
geldpolitisches phänomen
sobald eine zentralbank beginnt geld zu
drucken als gäbe es kein morgen mehr
wertet die währung nun mal ab aber warum
was ist der zusammenhang zwischen dem
drucken von geld und im wertverlust eben
dieses geldes nun wenn sie über eine
währung sprechen müssen wir diese
einfach als ein weiteres unter vielen
anderen produkt betrachten ja ihr habt
richtig gehört währungen funktionieren
nach den gleichen prinzipien öl bohren
oder handys angebot und nachfrage zum
beispiel wird er wenn diese organischen
kohle war nur wenig nachgefragt nur wenn
es von erna benutzen ihn wenn also die
zentralbank von pcgh viele olivas druckt
und damit viel geld versorgen ausweitet
cent der preis dieser bulli wahren
das heißt die währung wertet ab und die
nachfrage nach amerikanischen dollars
wie wächst und wächst
jeder auf der ganzen welt der
grenzüberschreitende handel treibt dies
bedeutet dass wir einen großen spielraum
hat geld zu drucken ohne eine abwertung
zu riskieren
und jetzt fragt ihr euch warum sollte
die herr gelddrucken
[Musik]
schauen wir uns ein beispiel an stell
dir vor du hättest der amerikanischen
regierung 100 dollar geliehen und jetzt
willst du dass die sie zurückzahlen
also gehst du zu ihr und die sagen dir
aber klar doch wieviel willst du 100
dollar kein problem alter gehe einfach
dort um die ecke in das gebäude auf dem
federal reserve bank steht und dort
siehst du dir deine 100 dollar frisch
aus der notenpresse diese praxis nennt
man monetisierung von staatsschulden und
wenn du deinem klugscheißer
verschwörungstheoretiker freund der sich
für einen experten im geopolitik hält
von dieser sache erzählt weil er keine
ahnung haben wovon du da überhaupt
sprichst
aber die wahrheit ist das ist der
leitwährung status des dollars dem us
ermöglicht mehr und mehr schulden zu
machen und das einfache als jedes andere
land und deswegen ist es vollkommen
normal schlagzeilen wie die folgende zu
lesen
[Musik]
amerikas schuldenkrise im anzug zinslast
wird eine billion dollar pro jahr
erreichen eine so große verschuldung zu
haben ist keine wirklich gute nachricht
für den amerikanischen steuerzahler in
einem anderen video haben wir das
erklärt oomen
ich weiß was erst denkt ist amerikas
geldpolitik jetzt genauso
unverantwortlich wie die argentiniens
oder venezuelas und die antwort ist
natürlich nicht dazu muss man verstehen
dass alle zentralbanken jahr für jahr
neues geld drucken und nicht nur drucken
sondern einfach elektronisch generieren
der unterschied liegt aber in den
proportionen in dieser grafik sieht man
den anstieg der geldmenge den wir m2
indikator der amerikanischen federal
reserve wie ihr sehen könnt wächst die
zahl der dollar jahr für jahr aber was
passiert wenn wir dies mit dem
amerikanischen lesung vergleichen nun
hier sieht den unterschied
und was passiert wenn wir den
medizinischen pulver hinzuziehen
dazu muss man glaube ich nichts mehr
sagen in nur neun jahren hat sich die
geldmenge in venezuela mehr als
verhundertfacht während die usa sie
nicht mal verdoppelt haben und nebenbei
bemerkt in dieser tabelle haben wir uns
entschieden das jahr 2018 überhaupt
nicht einzubeziehen da sonst der gelbe
bereich alles überdenken würde
in diesem jahr hat die zentralbank von
venezuela ihre geldmenge noch einmal
4000 und das ist einer der gründe warum
der amerikanischen dollar nun mal die am
meisten verwendete währung auf dem
planeten ist weil er so stabil ist
während andere zentralbanken geld wie
verrückt drucken handelt die federal
reserve eigentlich noch ziemlich
verantwortungsvollen und jetzt fragt ihr
euch vielleicht was passiert mit anderen
währungen wie zum beispiel dem schweizer
franken oder den britischen pfund wenn
es eine stabile währung auf diesem
planeten gibt dann ist das doch da
schweizer franken oder nun du hast recht
aber
jetzt passt mal gut auf denn das was
wäre jetzt sagen würde ich vielleicht
ein wenig überraschend obwohl der dollar
so wichtig ist ist er nicht die einzige
reservewährung auf diesem planeten
er ist sogar weit davon entfernt aber
jetzt eine welt mit vielen ehrungen
wir haben es schon zu beginn des videos
gesagt 60 prozent der devisenreserven
werden im greenbacks gehalten aber was
ist mit den übrigen 40 prozent
die am zweithäufigsten verwendete
währung ist der euro der 20 prozent der
reserven ausmachen
danach haben wir den japanischen yen und
das britische pfund aber das sind nicht
die einzigen viele zentralbanken haben
reserven die australische dollar oder
sogar schweizer franken lauten wenn auch
nicht ganz so beliebt wie der dollar
werden diese währung durchaus von vielen
als stabile anlage geschätzt
jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage
wenn stabilität der einzige faktor dafür
ist dass eine währung international
stark nachgefragt wird warum kaufen wir
dann nichts genauso viele schweizer
franken wie amerikanischen dollars
[Musik]
die antwort lautet auf dem markt gibt es
einfach viel weniger schweizer franken
als us-dollar überlegt mal die schweiz
hat achteinhalb millionen einwohner
die vereinigten staaten haben 300
millionen das bedeutet dass die
schweizerische nationalbank nicht so
viele geldscheine ausgeben muss erinnert
ihr euch noch daran dass sich besorgt
habe auf der welt wären 1,67 billionen
dollar im umlauf nun vom schweizer
franken ist es nicht einmal eine ganze
million das heißt dass es schwieriger
ist für eine transaktion einen franken
als einen dollar zu finden außerdem ist
amerika der größte markt der welt das
bedeutet dass tausende von unternehmen
auf der ganzen welt die ihre produkte
verkaufen wollen stell dir vor du bist
eine australische firma und verkaufs
handys in new york wo mit bezahlen die
kunden mit amerikanischen dollars und
natürlich was machst du dann mit diesen
greenbacks du schaust sie in deine
lokale währung und wer wird nun also das
amerikanische geld haben natürlich die
australische bank bei der duh den
umtausch getätigt hast mit anderen
worten je mehr amerika mit der welt
handelt desto mehr dollars werden rund
um den globus zirkulieren
es handelt sich also um eine währung die
stabil und im überfluss vorhanden ist
und von der stärksten wirtschaft der
welt unterstützt wird doch vor einigen
jahrzehnten konnte keine andere währung
an den greenback heranreichen aber wie
ihr wisst ändert sich die welt ständig
jetzt wisst ihr glaube ich langsam
worauf ich hinauswill zu beginn dieses
videos habe ich euch gefragt ist es
möglich dass der dollar seine
hegemoniale stellung verliert oder
zumindest an bedeutung eingebüßt die
antwort ist ja
[Musik]
während die usa america first trompeten
zieht der rest der welt weiter wir haben
euch woche für woche hier bei visual
politik davon erzählt donald trump
möchte die usa vor dem internationalen
handel schützen
sein erster schritt war die aufhebung
von freihandelsabkommen mit der eu und
asien
danach führt der zölle für stahl ein
einige unternehmen die stahl benötigen
wie zum beispiel harley davidson
beschlossen daraufhin das land zu
verlassen
trump hat auch angekündigt dass das
nafta handelsabkommen zwischen den usa
kanada und mexiko gekündigt wird
mit anderen worten trotz amerika will
sich stärker vom internationalen markt
isolieren was bedeutet das nun es
bedeutet dass die anderen in der weniger
dollars haben werden hinzu kommen
nachrichten wie diese
europäische zentralbanken beginnen ihre
dollarreserven durch den yuan zu
ersetzen
russland plant den verkauf von
staatsanleihen während es mit sanktionen
bedroht wird
jetzt sprüht aber nicht über vor
begeisterung es stimmt zwar dass der
chinesische yuan auch renminbi genannt
früher auf dem internationalen markt
eine fast unbekannte währung war er
wurde nur innerhalb chinas benutzt
nichtsdestotrotz haben in den letzten
jahren einige zentralbanken damit
angefangen yuan in ihre bestände
aufzunehmen das heißt aber nicht dass
diese banken von heute auf morgen alle
ihre dollars in diese währung umtauschen
tatsächlich gibt es sehr viele
unklarheiten in bezug auf die
chinesische währung unklarheiten von
denen auch dann von der klugscheißer mit
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
den blassesten schimmer haben wird aber
keine sorge denn in den nächsten wochen
wird es eine fortsetzung zu diesem video
geben also vergiss nicht visuell politik
zu abonnieren klicke auf das glöckchen
oben rechts und du wirst keinen beitrag
verpassen in der zwischenzeit könnte er
über ein paar fragen nachdenken und
diskutieren glaubt ihr dass der dollar
in den folgenden jahrzehnten seine
vorherrschaft behalten kann wenn nicht
welche andere währung könnte ihn
ersetzen
der yuan der euro vielleicht der bitcoin
hinterlasst eure antworten bitte im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video
falls ihr dieses video gefällt gibt uns
einen daumen nach oben und wie immer
sehen wir uns das nächste mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]